(audience cheers and applauds)
- I know.
Legend.
- Welcome to New York.
- [Kelly] Thank you, I love it.
- I'm so glad you're here.
- Man, I love it so much.
- You're living on the west side.
- I know, it's just
everything, the energy,
everything is very much me.
I'm very,
(Kelly exclaims)
- [Martha] Yeah, we know that.
- I do a lot, you do a lot.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- That's New York too.
- [Kelly] I know, but that's why I fit in.
Yeah, anything special for Thanksgiving?
- Oh, I gave up Thanksgiving.
I canceled, somebody canceled,
nine guests canceled
because somebody got sick.
- [Kelly] Oh, no.
- So I decided, I called
up my chef friend,
and I said, we're not doing Thanksgiving.
- Yeah.
- [Martha] And I've also
cooked like 14 turkeys already
for my TV show.
- [Kelly] You kind of done it.
Yeah.
- [Martha] And I still
have to do one more Turkey,
I think, on the Today Show.
- [Kelly] Full turkeyed out.
- I am turkeyed out.
- I hope you had Taco
Thursday or something on.
(Kelly and Martha laugh)
Yeah, just half way, have tacos.
- So, I'm going, no, I've made a plan.
Friends of a course
invited me to their home,
so I'm going to about five different homes
to taste different courses.
You know, do a.
- Oh my God, those friends
must be so stressed out.
- Oh, I hope so.
(audience laugh)
- [Kelly] Yeah.
I was like, if you were
coming to my house,
I would for sure lie and say I cooked it
and have somebody else do it.
(everyone laughs)
Oh my God, so this is, this is crazy.
So your first book came out
in 1982, which is insane.
Like, do you remember that moment?
Like when that was all,
- [Martha] Of course,
that was like a big thing for me.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
That was my first book, 'Entertaining'.
We had a party, and all parties we had,
so every one of my friends came
and we had set up stations in my backyard
in Westport, Connecticut.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And everybody cooked
different things from the book,
and we had hundreds of people come.
- Wow.
- [Martha] And it was so much fun.
And now I'm working on my 100th book.
- [Kelly] I was gonna say that, 100 books.
Did you ever think you'd, look at that?
(audience applauds)
- [Martha] Yeah.
- [Kelly] That's incredible.
Like.
- And I lined them all up like this.
- [Kelly] I mean, everybody,
like, I don't know,
I feel like there's a lot of
people that get into this world
that try and like say, oh,
I love cooking, I do that.
But you are the most successful at it.
So what is the trick?
- Well, I work hard.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Martha] I mean, I work hard.
- [Kelly] A lot of people work hard.
I think you're just like special.
- [Martha] I work everyday.
And I think about it while I'm asleep,
you know, I'm a workaholic.
- Yeah.
You know that it's your purpose?
- I like it, I like it.
- Yeah.
I love though that we both
have worked with Snoop.
You had worked with Snoop the
last time I talked to you,
but I've worked with him since then.
- [Martha] Yeah.
- [Kelly] I love working with him.
- [Martha] Great, he's great.
- [Kelly] I know, he's so much fun.
So I feel like in your
next a hundred books
that you're gonna put
out, you should do one.
Have you ever infused,
weeded into your foods?
- I haven't yet, not yet, but I might.
- [Kelly] This is a great idea.
- You never know.
- But you just have to watch out.
- You have a person to taste test for you.
- [Martha] Of course.
And a provider too, you know.
- [Kelly] Exactly, a provider.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
I love this,
and this is also why I
wanna be your friend,
because I know that you
did something for your
granddaughter, I believe.
She's 12, right?
- Yep.
- [Kelly] She had like six friends over
and you had, was it an
autumn weekend sleepover?
- Yeah, a couple weeks ago
she brought five friends.
So there's six girls
and I persuaded them all
to sleep in the Woodland cottage.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Which is the chart most chart,
oh, there's Jude.
She's taller than I am now.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- She's an amazing girl.
And so much fun.
- Yeah.
- And she entertained her friends.
She had an agenda.
It was typed up for me, two
page agenda for the weekend.
- [Kelly] So she's you?
- [Martha] Yeah well,
she's more than I am.
I mean, my gosh, two pages.
It was making, picking
apples, making apple cider.
- [Kelly] She's organized.
- [Martha] Yeah, totally organized.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Martha] Bottling the cider.
Then we had lunch that I had to make.
I made all the food for
the girls that weekend.
- She's got it made.
- [Martha] And one of the mothers came
and she was all dressed up.
The mother came with the daughter.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And this is a new friend.
I had never met this
friend or mother before.
And the mother came all
dolled up with spiked heels
and I live on a farm
and she could hardly walk
on the stones and stuff.
- She's like, aerating your grass.
- And then she saw how we lived.
She'd come, next day she came back
to pick her up and she was in jeans.
I hardly recognized her.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, it was so funny.
- Well, I get it, it's
a little intimidating.
Like, your kid's going
over to Martha Stewart's
and you're like, what do I wear?
- [Martha] I didn't even know if she knew
I was Martha Stewart.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- You know, I didn't know.
And one kid did not want to
stay in the Woodland cottage,
which is way far from my house.
It's like a mile from my house.
- [Kelly] Oh, she was too scared.
- [Martha] And she was scared.
She said, I don't like nature.
I said, buck it up, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
(audience laugh)
- Where has that parenting gone?
- [Martha] There's no electricity.
There's no running water.
- Yeah.
- There's no bathroom, nothing.
- Yeah, it's like camping.
- What if I have to go pee?
And I said, the woods.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- The woods.
- And I said, don't be
afraid of the coyotes
or the foxes, you know?
- Yeah.
- She stayed out all
night, she was excellent.
- [Kelly] I will say, I'm
just like you on my ranch.
But the difference is, is
that we have like, you know,
grizzly bear and mountain
lions and wolves,
like things that can actually kill you.
But, but I do, I've peed all over it.
(audience laugh)
Because there was no bathroom,
and we stay in little cabins as well.
It's beautiful.
- [Martha] Oh, isn't it fun?
- [Kelly] Yes, it's beautiful.
- We went pumpkin picking.
They carved pumpkins.
- [Kelly] No, I'm saying
I want to be a friend.
I want to come over and do this.
- [Martha] Okay.
They had so much fun
and they were excellent.
Excellent.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's so cool.
What a beautiful experience
that all those girls have.
- Oh, yeah.
- [Kelly] That's special.
I want you to explain though,
the world of Martha Project.
What is this?
- The world of Martha Project?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Well, we're just, we're working on
so many wonderful new things.
Our products for the home are beautiful.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Wonderful, Martha by
Martha's pots and pans,
towels, sheets.
I just got back from India
to visit my manufacturer.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- In India with a state-of-the-art
textile factories.
It was very fun.
I mean, I had never been to Mumbai.
Have you been?
- [Kelly] No.
- [Martha] Oh, it's so,
- I've always, India's one
place I wanna go, yeah.
- [Martha] Oh, it's crazy crowded
and crazy noisy and colorful, but, oh,
- That sounds like me.
- But it's, yes.
It's, a lot of fun to see
where things are being created now.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Martha] And we
design, they manufacture.
We had a very interesting time.